so just before we came on there you were
talking about swords
yes um always a fun thing to have a
sword so one of the skills then that you
have picked up as you were just about to
tell me and i was like adam no this is
good stuff for the podcast just wait
uh it sounds like when you were down in
new zealand that was another skill you
picked up well so on that first day that
i was visiting where i met peter lyon
the swordmaster at wetta who built all
the swords for all the lord of the rings
films
hand ground them
i mean it's just their amazing work
uh and he showed me sting he showed me
the original sting
and
we came back to san francisco and i
started corresponding with richard i
said i want to come back down i want to
film some stuff and he said what do you
want to film and i said i'd love to
spend a few days learning sword grinding
from peter lyon
uh and so we did i came back and he
helped me taught me how to grind i made
aragorn's sword out of aluminum like a
stunt sword
[Music]
you're shining bright i'm your voice the
baby you're my pearl